hello everybody markiplier here
welcoming you to my or to Rueter err
where every Sunday this month we will be
live-streaming a full brand-new amnesia
custom story for your entertainment
every Sunday starting at 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time and it all culminates to
the 28th of October where we will be
running our second 12-hour charity
livestream where I will be
live-streaming nothing but horror the
entire time so I hope you'll be ready to
join me over on my twitch channel
alright enough of that silliness in all
honesty yes we are doing another 12 hour
charity livestream on October 28th on
Sunday that is a Sunday on October 28th
starting at 10:00 a.m. running until
10:00 p.m. and we are probably going to
be raising money for some breast cancer
research I'm not sure which one I have
to pick out a very good one a very
reputable charity and I'm not sure that
susan g komen for the Cure or whatnot
but i'll figure it out and i'll let you
guys know but really honestly and truly
guys it is incredible what we've been
able to do with just the limited number
of people that we have and every day
every day we get hundreds of new
subscribers it's outrageous for a
channel my size to be growing this
quickly and I thank only you only you
guys are the only reason that we're
growing as quickly as we are and we're
doing what we have been doing and I
haven't lost sight of that even though
we gained a thousand new people every
week there are people in now I'm
speaking directly to my new viewers who
have no idea of Who I am all they know
is that I make semi entertaining you
videos where I scream like a little girl
for people that entertainment but I want
to build so much more I want to give
back so much more and I think I think
you guys every single day because I know
that other channels aren't lucky enough
to have a fanbase as great as you have
viewers who are as dedicated and giving
and hardworking as you guys it's
incredible and every viewer who just
views my videos likes it Thomas doesn't
matter it doesn't matter to me the
numbers because I only care that you
guys are such an amazing community that
has inspired me to do more that's why I
want to give you guys what you want I
know everyone loved the SCP o 87b live
stream I know you did so I am definitely
inclined to give you guys more horror
all month long and we are doing a full
and needs a custom story every Sunday
leading up to the live stream of the
charity stream so I hope you guys will
join me for that and it's just
oh it's just incredible to know that all
of you are there for me all of you who
have got my back like I'm inspired by
you guys because I personally I can do
nothing but play video games and speak
into a camera I can't do anything more
than that and you guys pushing me to
work harder every day to try to improve
myself and improve everything that we do
and I do for the channel it's it's the
only driving force that motivates me and
it's more than enough it's incredible
that's all it is what we've been able to
do so I really really really sincerely
thank you each and every one of you for
everything that you've done for me
because this this is changing my life
YouTube this you guys are you're
changing my life I never thought I'd be
doing this let me tell you I never
imagined that I'd be doing this for a
living and now I'm approaching that
point because uh
and no other channel is lucky enough to
have the growth that I am right now I
don't want to take advantage of it I
want to use it for improving you know
improving the world
just I'm rambling now so just thank you
guys each and every one thank you so
much from the bottom of my heart
so anyway to wrap up wrap up live
streams every Sunday full and music cuts
um sorry for the short one I might do
two so be ready for that and as always
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye